what if we can
replace the
electronics with fiber based photonic
Computing that means to take a
fiber which is a piece of glass
elongated
glass and somehow to turn it from a
something that carries photons from
point A to point
B to something that processes the data
when the photons pass through it
[Music]
he Al and welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you I'm very well thank
you thank you for having me thank you
for it's great to have an
audience and through you I hope that
people will understand many things that
still seem like science fiction let's
talk about science fiction a you're a
co-founder and CEO of cogni fiber um in
the space of photonic
Computing what is that photonic
Computing in the basic it's Computing
with photons instead of electrons so our
whole technology world today is based on
electronics mostly but until now we
didn't have any issue with it I mean it
functioned very well we did amazing
things with
that until we reached AI
and artificial
intelligence is really challenging for
any type of
Hardware because the demand for
trillions of operation every
second is very heavy on on the
hardware and you can see it in the cost
of Hardware in the cost of
operation and electrical builds and and
the cooling it needs m
mhm uh it's simply because when you want
to transfer trillions of electrons every
second through wires they heat
up and they cannot move as fast as
photons so 11 years ago I asked
myself okay we have very nice Optical
communication high speed very low power
especially the fibers because they are
really really
efficient in transferring
photons so what if we can
replace the
electronics with fiber based photonic
Computing that means to take a fiber
which is a piece of glass elongated
glass and somehow to turn it from a
something that carries for photons from
point A to point
B to something that processes the data
when the photons pass through
it and that's the basic idea so if I
understand correctly um a big part of it
is is adapting the the the photonic
technology from just being a data
transfer layer to also being to having a
compute capability right yeah yes I mean
we can look at the basic uh
example if we want to implement let's
say a gate and electronic gate simple
end gate or
gate or if we want to implement a
neuron like in artificial neural
networks so if we can do it in photonics
it would be very fast
it could reach let's say 100 Gig today
200 gig 400
gig and on the other hand it wouldn't
take a lot of power it wouldn't heat up
as
much so that seems like a win-win
situation and so so tell me a little bit
about the where we're at in terms of
productization and with just for that so
that we have a good basis for the market
Landscaping so where are we at today
with with this technology with this with
other with companies building on top of
this of the promise of photonic
Computing um and what timelines are we
talking
about so we have today in the world
about two or three main Technologies of
photonic
Computing the first family is based on
Silicon chips
and they are called silicon photonics or
photonic integrated
circuits and that's adding additional
layers on top of silicon
chips so they can become a wave guides
to guide
light and most of the companies
today use this these
Technologies the main issue is uh the
packaging of the
processors and
scalability so if we want to implement
for example
jgpt or other generative AI
models we need hundreds of billions of U
of processors or let's say U
parameters mhm
and the down the downside with phons
it's their
wavelength their wavelength is much
longer than
electrons that means that every uh
component is much
larger so let's say 10 x 10 microns for
example as compared to a transistor of
several hundreds of
nanometers so that's about one one 1 to
100 ratio could be 1 to th000
ratio so things are
bigger but they're much
faster and lower on
energy on the other hand when we look at
fibers the issue of H packaging is
similar but the
scalability is much easier
because we can uh just connect fibers to
fibers in regular connection you can
find the millions of them in data
centers so we can actually physically
build very
large network of
processors so is is this the world that
we're heading into that data centers and
the the the the data computation layer
within our Hardware eventually will be
um fiber and photons instead of the
instead of what we have today so I think
eventually if we look 50 years
ahead we'll have three types of
computing
machines we'll have the quantum
machines for specific problems which are
let's say very hard very
complex we'll have the photonic
machines which can do uh let's say
trillions of full operations every
second that means accelerate about a
million times from
today let's say instead of millions of
inferences per second we go to billions
and
trillions of inference per
second and of course we'll still have
the
iics for control for training for a lot
of things which are more
convenient to to make it eventually we
might go to fully
photonics but it will take a lot of time
okay so that's the
vision so so yeah tell me about Give an
example yeah go
ahead one photonic
machine let's say 10 years ago 10 years
ahead 10 years ahead sorry uh will
replace half of the data center
today h okay that's the ratio of
computing
capabilities
wow okay so a tell me a little bit about
tell me about cogni fiber so the this is
so now you're you're you're an
entrepreneur in the space tell me about
the company founded how the the journey
so far and and really what is it that
you're bringing to be part of the larger
vision of photonics in the
world yeah so cogn fiber is about a very
unique
connection between the world of Optics
and
photonics represented by our CTO
Professor Zev
zki which is a world-renowned photonic
researcher
and myself coming from uh both
Hardware but also the brain research as
my PhD was in
neuroscience and I'm lecturing about the
brain for 20 years
now so this combination of
Hardware brain
neuroscience and Optics
is is something which is unique to
cognitive fiber
and we use this uh Advantage so we look
at the
brain we look for how the brain does it
efficiently how how does it
compute I mean what's the difference
between regular computers and servers
and the
brain of course we are not alone uh the
field of
neuromorphics is a very wide field deal
with
that uh but I think that stepping into
the knowledge that I gathered about the
brain for the last 20
years with the knowledge in photonics
they have an I
bring that is the major advantage and
the also the source of uh
differentiators of the
company so for
example our V for inference
systems systems where the data streams
in from regular fibers in the data
centers and streams through the system
and and does the inference without any
reading or writing to
memory that is a unique um let's say
strategy which give us a a very strong
advantage in latency and throughput and
what how does the product then come to
Market what is the product that you're
building for the
Layman so for we we start with small
networks and will grow uh
gradually so we look at the next year
we'll have machine Learning
Systems which are very very fast
especially low
latency they could go for the market for
example high frequency tra
where they every microsc
counts or they go to Data Center
switching to make the training of AI
generative models much more
efficient is the play here to work with
the larger Hardware companies to bring
this to Market as part of their Hardware
or how what is the play to Market
here yes first we want to show the world
that this actually works and works well
so the first PC's will probably without
a large
partners and then we can get the
traction um yes we are in contact with
Intel with Samsung with
Nidia and
um and some of them are really waiting
to see how our first uh products
work they understand the
value yeah so it's about the next two
years
yeah when you show the product and you
try to express the value what what are
the key metrics that that that you care
about is it mainly the latency and the
efficiency of the
computation yeah if we look at the first
uh product the simple
ones it's mostly about real time uh
pattern
recognition and we talk about let's say
two up to 10 nond
delay m that's something which is does
not exist
today if we talk about future system
which are
larger we're talking about let's say the
total cost of ownership of a query for
let's say generative
AI but also latency because the
customers do want very short
latency yeah so and people talk about
throughput and uh how to divide
the let's say the bandwidth possible
bandwidth between customers
Etc so speed is of the
essence and but if you look also there
are some
fields that cannot exist today so we and
we are
enablers for example Smart
City so today if a smart City wants to
connect 100,000
cameras they need a data center
that's right okay and they cannot afford
a data
center most
cities and if we can provide them a
system let's say 3040
million does most of the
work let's say only a small
room with some well several other
pods that would be
enough so then you can have a smart
city I mean and the electrical bill will
be you know
about 20 kilowatt 50 kilowatt and not 20
megawatt that's a you know
basic Revol
Revolution amazing wow so a what's
coming up in the next couple months for
cogni
fiber we are very excited because we are
going to present our first uh prototype
and it's actually
MVP and uh with this uh presentation
somewhere along the next q1
2025 we are going to present this
technology the aim is at least one gig
inference per
second and with power consumption of up
to 100 VT
and that's like you know saying we are
here there's a new technology in you
know rising up and you better not miss
it absolutely a thank you so much for
coming and for sharing your journey um
sounds like we're in it for the long
haul and and especially it sounds like
this is a very foundational and very
fundamental um technology that will
change how we experience a lot of
different existing new is new use cases
um and of course we're all getting less
and less patient every day so the so so
considering the the impact of latency
and the speed I think that's really the
key here so a thank you again and best
of luck with cogni fiber thank you thank
you too Michael thank you for the time
thank you so much